resuelve el logaritmo de x el 19 3 es
igual a 2 veces el lugar y 94 menos el
logaritmo de 2 y lo primero que quiero
hacer es reescribir esta ecuación aquí y
tengo el logaritmo de x + logaritmo de 3
es igual a dos veces el logaritmo de
cuatro menos el logaritmo de dos y
recuerda que cuando vemos logaritmo lo
que te tienes que acordar es que estamos
hablando de un logaritmo en base 10 así
que cada vez que vemos logaritmo estamos
hablando el logaritmo en base 10 en base
10 en base 10 sin embargo para
simplificarlo a partir de ahora no voy a
poner la base solamente voy a poner
logaritmo y tú sabes que cuando esté
hablando del logaritmo me refiero a
logaritmo en base 10 por ejemplo aquí me
estoy refiriendo 10 a que potencia meta
x 10 elevado a qué potencia me da 3 y
así todos los demás entonces lo que
quiero recordar es todas las propiedades
los logaritmos que hemos visto que nos
van a servir bastante para simplificar
esta ecuación y la primera propiedad dos
logaritmos que habíamos visto era la
siguiente te acuerdas logaritmo en base
a debe más logaritmo en base a de sem es
igual a logaritmo en base a de b
recuerda que se pasan multiplicando esta
va a ser mi primera propiedad después
vemos una siguiente propiedad que vamos
a apuntarle aquí la cual decía a veces
el logaritmo en base deja mejor
escribirlo todo en la misma base y me
queda de veces el logaritmo en base a de
c esto es exactamente lo mismo que el
logaritmo en base a esto usando la misma
base de ese elevado a la vez esta era la
segunda propiedad primera propiedad de
una propiedad y teníamos la tercera
propiedad que se derivaba de estas dos
que decía que el logaritmo en base a
debe menos el logaritmo en base a de c
esto es exactamente lo mismo que
lograremos en base a debe en 13 la
diferencia de logaritmos pasaba adentro
de un solo logaritmo en una división y
bueno aquí tenemos estas tres
propiedades de los organismos que voy a
ocupar en esta ecuación logarítmica para
obtener el valor de x para despejar a x
y si te das cuenta esta primera parte de
esta ecuación estos 2 se pueden reducir
con la primera propiedad de los
logaritmos porque aquí tengo una suma de
logaritmos y esto lo puedo pasar como el
logaritmo en base 10
3 x x o de x x 3 de 3 x se van a pasar
multiplicando porque tengo una suma de
logaritmos aquí tengo esta parte de azul
que es esta segunda propiedad que dice
dos veces el logaritmo en base 10 de 4
yo sé que el 2 lo puedo pasar como
potencias y esto me quedaría el
logaritmo envase de 10 de 4 elevado al
cuadrado lo cual es 16 esto de aquí me
queda como el logaritmo en base 10 de 16
es decir de 4 elevado al cuadrado porque
el 2 entra dentro del logaritmo como
potencia y después tengo menos el
logaritmo en base 10 dedos y date cuenta
aquí aquí tengo una resta aquí puedo
utilizar la tercera propiedad de los
logaritmos por lo tanto esta parte de
aquí me queda como logaritmo en base de
10 de 16 entre 2 porque tengo una resta
de logaritmos pero 16 entre 2 es lo
mismo que 8 entonces mejor dejar de
escribir 8 el organismo en base 10 de 8
y del lado izquierdo no olvidemos
tenemos el logaritmo envase 10 de 3x y
ojo aquí viene un paso muy importante
aquí estoy diciendo 10 elevado a que
potencia me da 3x y aquí te estoy
diciendo 10 elevado a qué potencia me da
8 pero estas dos cosas son iguales por
otras
no queda de otra 3x tiene que ser igual
a 8 es como si cancelamos el logaritmo
como los logaritmos tienen la misma base
no hay de otra tiene que ser que 13 x
sea igual a 8 iraqiya podemos dejar a x
dividido ambas partes entre 3 me queda
que x igual a 8 tercios perfecto ya
logramos encontrar la solución de x
y es que darte cuenta que tiene todo el
sentido del mundo sec y pongo el valor
de x me queda 3 por 8 tercios lo cual es
8 y me quedaría el lugar en base de 10
de 8 es igual al organismo en base 10 de
8 que es justo lo que yo quería pero
bueno también hay otro método
alternativo de resolver esta misma
ecuación justo en este paso yo puedo
poner 10 elevado a logaritmo en base 10
de 3x y 10 elevado al hogar en un base
de 10 de 8 es decir 10 elevado a la
potencia lo que tengo que elevar 10 para
que me dé 3x pues estos 3 x y 10 elevado
a la potencia de la que tengo que llevar
10 para que me dé 8 pues esto es 8 y me
quedaría de nuevo 3x es igual a 8 o si
resolvemos x es igual a 8 tercios y
llegamos al mismo resultado